alright back from Vegas lost my money at
the craps tables got it back at
blackjack now I'm back and let's review
captain Phillips captain Phillips
so captain Phillips stars Tom Hanks in
which he plays captain Phillips this is
a true story of a hostage situation that
happened one of those really big cargo
ships you know those ships that
transport goods it has to happen on this
particular day a group of four pirates
board the ship and it was a hostage
situation and a really bad shitty day in
Captain Phillips life this movie is a
real representation of piracy no Pirates
of the Caribbean you're like pirates and
they're Johnny Depp and they're all
likeable and quirky and that's cool no
they're douchebags and they're [ __ ]
and they take hostages and they steal
[ __ ] this movie does a really good job
at setting up the pirates side of it I'm
not saying it does that weird PC [ __ ]
where it's like well a perspective who's
right when clearly they're douchebags
I'm just saying it shows a good job at
showing how much pressure this dude was
under to board the ship and take it over
you know you have a dick boss and when
you don't do what your dick boss wants
he yells at you and you get scolded
you're like that's a [ __ ] day imagine
that but your dick boss has an ak-47 and
he's threatening people you can tell
this main pirate is like my boss is such
a dick this movie starts out cool has
really good set up when these pirates
board the ship that was intense when
you're on the ship you're like dude it
says hi just everyone hide from the
[ __ ] in about halfway through this
movie it becomes a hostage situation
type scenario but it's a realistic
hostage situation type of scenario which
means not a lot happens seriously if you
look at a real hostage situation a lot
of people are just standing around
waiting for [ __ ] to happen so I'm
talking going on about a lot of stuff
which it's a sit still well done I'm
just saying the movie slowed down a bit
about halfway through then the last act
of the movie happens and then it picks
up again you're like oh cool right now
we're back and stride as for Tom Hanks
in this movie I heard this was just like
the greatest performance Tom Hanks has
ever done in his life ever from a couple
people which is bold because the dude
has a really he has a laundry list of
really good [ __ ] under his bow and for a
lot of this movie I was like yeah Tom
Hanks is good I'm not saying it's the
greatest performance of his career but
he's really good in it but there is one
scene in the movie I'm just saying if
Anne Hathaway got nominated for an Oscar
for a song Tom Hanks should get some
[ __ ] for this scene the scene I really
believe this dude was in shock
you're watching
you're like this tom hanks is actually
in shock and you guys think they film
this movie a while ago here's what
happened they probably filmed it on this
Sunday box office mojo just came out
with the weekend numbers Pacific Rim
didn't perform as much as it should have
Tom Hanks was just beside himself trying
to do his lines but he forgetting them
and he's in shock the director was like
keep rolling you will use this just keep
it on him but no it's just a realistic
take on shock I was like this is really
killing me it was just a rough scene I
did it was good it it almost made the
movie if the movie itself wasn't still
really good so in the end captain
Phillips had great setup it was really
good it was intense and more than a
couple of scenes everyone was really
good in the movie these nuke these dudes
who play the Pirates are brand new brand
new to acting in general and they were
awesome
it slows down about halfway through the
movie the movies about two hours 15
minutes long I don't know if they could
have made the movie shorter but because
the middle part is a bit slow I feel
like they should have I will say captain
Phillips is definitely worth buying on
blu-ray right so your favorite hostage
situation movie what is it whatever it
be comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you